creo que aquí todos el día de nuestros
cumpleaños nos levantamos y apenas nos
levantamos nuestros abuelos nos empiezan
a llamar en mi caso siempre ha sido mis
abuelos paternos los primeros en
llamarme hace tres años me levanté el
día de mi cumpleaños para ir al colegio
y apenas me desperté mis abuelos me
habían llamado hablé con ambos para
visitarme pero lo que impactó mi día fue
cuando más llamadas de mi abuelo de mi
abuela llegaron porque se había olvidado
haber hablado conmigo
me encuentro con el fantasma del
alzheimer llegó inesperadamente primero
en mi vida diaria eleven grupos
vulnerables de esta sociedad según la
clínica mayo esta enfermedad está
definida como un trastorno progresivo
que hace que las células del cerebro se
consuman y mueran además las
estadísticas de una investigación hecha
por la universidad san francisco de
quito dice que existe alrededor de 110
mil personas que padecen alzheimer y que
hay muy poco de estudios sobre esta
enfermedad el impacto que esta
enfermedad neuro generativa tiene en el
adulto mayor su entorno familiar y la
sociedad
me encuentro con el alzheimer llegó
primero con mi abuelo materno que vive
en canadá a quien le diagnosticaron
alzheimer en abril del 2007 y el otro
como abuela paterna que vive en quito
aquí le hicieron varios exámenes pues
los doctores nunca concluyeron
exactamente qué tipo de mensaje ya tenía
estos dos hechos hicieron que me empecé
a preguntar qué les está pasando porque
con el tiempo mi abuela iba perdiendo
más del conocimiento del tiempo
a su alrededor y la memoria me puede dar
cuenta claramente de esto cuando ella me
contaba unas de las mil anécdotas que
tiene como abuela ella se perdiendo la
conversación y empezaba a contar una
historia distinta o incluso la misma
pero es otro momento
fue ahí cuando empecé a investigar lo
que es el alzheimer y encontré varias
información en diferentes tipos en
diferentes páginas de internet
y empecé a investigar sobre lo que es de
esto me di cuenta que tiene una duración
entre 10 y 12 años según la persona me
di cuenta que el momento indicado para
poder trabajar con mis dos abuelos
toca admitir que al principio cuando yo
tenía que hacer mi proyecto personal yo
quería trabajar con perros callejeros
para ver cómo al pasar de los días me
haber ido perdiendo más la memoria
decidí dedicar mi proyecto
durante mis visitas a la fundación está
se me puede dar cuenta de algo que nunca
antes me había dado había notado existe
una barrera entre los adultos mayores y
los jóvenes una especie de que me
importe no de parte de los jóvenes y una
especie de desconfianza de parte de los
adultos mayores esa barrera puede
explicar la falta interés que hay cuando
de ayuda se trata por ejemplo
hoy en día es muy común que un joven
estoy psicología por el momento escoger
su especialización muy pocos de escogen
nora psicología dedicada adulto mayor
por cuanto el adulto mayor no está
acostumbrado este tipo de ayuda cuando
le sugerimos que ellos necesitan una
ayuda especial algunos de ellos
reaccionan como si les dijéramos que
están locos resistiendo seguir a un
centro de ayuda
y para estimular sus neuronas
y hombre para un cuaderno de 96 páginas
con actividades diversas colorear
mandalas realizar operaciones
matemáticas
en sopas de letras
llenar hojas de información de sus vidas
este cuaderno está pasado toda manera
porque los adultos mayores durante toda
su vida escribieron en mano escrita
desde muy chiquitos entonces ahora se
les hace mucho más fácil escribir esa
manera al utilizar letra grande también
facilita a que ellos puedan leer con
claridad el uso de colores también ayuda
a que ellos puedan trabajar de una
manera mucho más divertida
mi primer objetivo con esto era que
ellos puedan porque es efectiva para las
tres etapas del alzheimer inicial
moderada y final comienza con la etapa
final en la cual el adulto mayor ya no
puede controlarse por sí mismo por esta
razón lo único que hay para ellos en el
cuaderno es canciones ecuatorianos que
les encanta escuchar van pasando las
hojas y los ejercicios se van haciendo
más difíciles esto hace que una persona
de la segunda etapa pueda realizar los
ejercicios hasta un cierto punto una
persona de la primera etapa poder llegar
a realizar todos los ejercicios
mi segundo objetivo con este cuaderno no
es que las ramas desaparezca pero ayuda
a estimular las neuronas de una manera
estimular las neuronas
durante mis visitas
bueno entonces este es el cuaderno y mi
segundo objetivo también es que como
dije no es que es la mesa parezca sino
más bien es que ellos pueden trabajar
las áreas de memoria cálculo lenguaje y
atención
también visitas de la fundación está se
me di cuenta que hay adultos increíbles
que realmente abren las puertas a
nosotros los jóvenes y te brindan todo
el cariño posible pero no va a negar
tampoco que era difícil trabajar con
algunos de ellos hay adultos que se
cierran un poco nosotros en cambio
nosotros que se abren un montón
cuando a los adultos mayores les
sugieren que necesitan ayuda como dije
antes algunos de ellos realizan como si
les dijéramos están locos
nuestra sociedad no sabe lo que es del
alzheimer está cerrado este tema
entonces cuando un adulto mayor empieza
a tener sus problemas la familia le
trata como si está loco y
no saben cómo tratarlo entonces
a raíz de la muerte de paterna de mi
abuela en abril del 2010 y otro el
estado media presida por esta razón le
hicieron exámenes de memoria de su
cabeza en general fue en abril del 2019
que había novela le confirmaron
alzhéimer ella asiste un centro de ayuda
en donde para tres veces a la semana y
ahí es donde pasa sus días y la ayuda
montón
y espero que con esto ustedes cambien
sus carreras de psicología ni mucho
menos promocione esta carrera si bien es
cierto para el 2050 vale el doble de
casos de lo que hay hoy en día de
alzheimer y por más que no todos
nuestros abuelos tienen alzheimer algún
tipo de demencia o enfermedad creo en la
necesidad de creer la importancia de
agradecer a esta generación que nos ha
traído a donde estamos parados hoy de
los adultos mayores necesitan de nuestra
ayuda de nuestro cariño y es algo que no
es difícil dar de nuestra parte